personas compran una casa deben pedir un
préstamo que sea alguna parte del precio
de compra de la casa así que digamos
tenemos aquí una casita y el precio de
compra es de doscientos mil doscientos
mil pesos y yo quiero comprar esta casa
ahora yo ahorre cuarenta mil pesos yo
ahorre 40 mil pesos estos son mis
ahorros así que yo usaré esto como un
pago de entrada pero aún necesito un
préstamo para poder llegar a los 200 mil
así que bueno requiero del préstamo y lo
que bueno le vamos a restar 200 mil
menos 40 que ya que ya di así que son
160 mil pesos que requiero yo de
préstamos 160 mil pesos 160 mil como un
préstamo y el tipo de préstamo que la
gente obtiene para comprar una casa se
le llama una hipoteca hipoteca y bueno
una hipoteca es simplemente un préstamo
si no llegas a pagar ese préstamo
entonces la persona que te prestó esa
persona se queda con la casa otra manera
de pensar lo sería que es un préstamo
que está asegurado por la casa y hasta
que pagues ese préstamo entonces
a tu casa mientras no lo es y bueno si
no lo pagas el banco vendrá y tomara la
casa a eso se le llama una ejecución de
hipoteca y bueno yo quiero en este vídeo
darte al menos el inicio de un
entendimiento de lo que hacen las
diferentes los diferentes tipos de
préstamos hipotecarios darte la
información básica de lo que significa
cada uno de estos préstamos de estos
diferentes préstamos así que supongamos
que estoy en el mercado y ya voy a pedir
el préstamo de 160 mil pesos si tú miras
cualquier página de internet sobre
finanzas o portales de finanzas te darán
cuotas de hipotecas y verás algo de este
estilo como estos números que tengo yo
aquí yo los hice muy sencillos estos
porcentajes normalmente vendrán con
decimales 5.54 punto 18% y bueno son los
diferentes tipos de tasas que tú verás
pero si consultas a un agente
hipotecario seguro te dará otros más
exóticos
estos son los comunes y espero con esto
quede claro al menos la noción de lo que
es de lo que son las tasas de hipotecas
una hipoteca fija a 30 años sigue
que tu pago y tu tasa de interés están
fijos a 30 años y en el transcurso de
esos 30 años tú pagarás tu préstamo así
que en esta situación esto lo voy a
escribir pensemos en una hipoteca fija a
30 años hipoteca fija a 30 años o qué
vamos a pensar en eso lo que va a pasar
es que tú tendrás vas a tener un pago
fijo hipotecario cada mes
aquí dibujaré una gráfica para mostrar
tu pago y bueno ya verás por qué hago
esta gráfica tú ten paciencia espera un
segundo ok entonces cada una de estas
barras representa tu pago mensual para
un aparece mes no hemos hecho cálculos
para saber en realidad cuándo se debe
pagar de los 160 mil pesos de y el 5%
pero supongamos que
no sé 22 mil pesos por simplicidad al
mes se pagan dos mil pesos aquí pongo
altura una altura entonces aquí aquí son
dos mil pesos al mes este aquí dos mil
pesos y este de acá es el mes primero el
1 mes uno luego pagas dos mil pesos en
el mes dos y así vas a seguir si tienes
30 años por 12 meses llegarás al mes 360
y ese va a ser tu último pago 360 será
el último pago en el año 30 y bueno al
final final final fin habrás pagado su
deuda lo interesante aquí es que en el
primer mes como pediste tanto dinero 160
mil pesos y en intereses entonces será
bastante lo que se tendrá que pagar
entonces la mayoría de los pagos
iniciales van a ser intereses lo pondré
aquí en la gráfica el interés en
diferente color en este primer mes bueno
mejor no es el no mejor morado en ese
primer pago será la mayor parte
compuesta por intereses y solamente una
pequeña parte de la verdadera deuda así
que esto es verde de aquí
el verdadero pago entonces digamos que
después de ese primer mes la parte
principal de los dos mil pesos son por
simplicidad digamos que 200 pesos y 1800
en la parte de intereses y bueno como tú
puedes ver aquí no estoy no estoy siendo
precisa con lo que en realidad estamos
asumiendo ni siquiera debes ni siquiera
deben ser 160 mil pesos vaya pero la
idea general es que después de este
primer pago es que pagaste 200 pesos de
tu préstamo entonces si si fuera una
deuda de 160 mil después de ese primer
mes tú ya no debes 160 mil pesos tú no
debes 160 mil menos 2 mil pesos no
porque 1800 fue de intereses ahora lo
que debes son lo que es equivalente a
159 mil 800 pesos entonces en el
siguiente periodo tus intereses van a
ser un poquito menos digamos que algo
así y como tu pago es fijo de 2000 tu
pago principal va a ser un poquitito más
digamos que 202 pesos 202 pesos y
seguida de esta manera de tal modo que
en él
y me pago ya estás pagando muy poco de
intereses y ahora si la mayor parte de
esos pagos es para el pago principal
entonces van a ser así muy poco de
intereses y el resto ahora sí va a ser
para pagar la deuda y al fin serás libre
después de ese último pago ahora esto
pasará en 30 años es un término de 30
años para una tasa fija de 15 años es
exactamente la misma idea
excepto bueno la única diferencia es que
en lugar de tomar 30 años para pagar la
deuda lo harás en 15 años así que en
lugar de ser 360 meses en el caso de 15
años serán 180 meses 15 años por 12
meses son 180 meses y por esa causa tu
pago por el mismo préstamo implica ahora
mayor pago cada mes porque lo estás
pagando más rápido lo estás pagando en
menor cantidad de meses en lugar de 2000
serían por ejemplo dos mil 800 pesos
para este caso de 15 años porque lo
estás pagando con mayor rapidez ahora
este caso el 51
ht a es una hipoteca de precio ajustable
ahorita te digo hay varios tipos de
hipotecas de este estilo las 5 1 es la
más usada y h tea significa hipotecas de
tasa ajustable hipotecas de tasa
ajustable entonces eso es ht am y bueno
como lo puedes ver aquí teníamos la
palabra fijo y así se les llama porque
la tasa de interés estaba fija
cualquiera que fuera tu balance de
préstamo restante pagabas la misma
cantidad de intereses para cada uno de
los periodos hasta terminar así que para
esta tasa fija de 30 años se nos está
cobrando una tasa del 5% fija para la de
15 años se nos está cobrando una tasa
fija del 4% para la ht a la tasa puede
variar y bueno como lo dije antes esta
51 es la más común de las hipotecas con
tasa ajustable la idea general detrás de
una hipoteca con tasa ajustable es que
la tasa de interés que pagarás en tu
balance restante cambiará acorde a un
índice y los casos más comunes de
hipoteca de tasa ajustable son estas de
aquí
esta es una hipoteca de tasa ajustable
mixta y la puedes ver como una
combinación de dos cosas y bueno te vas
a preguntar qué será esto de una
hipoteca de tasa ajustable mixta es la
que tiene una tasa fija por algún cierto
periodo en este caso es una tasa fija
para cinco años y la tasa de interés
puede cambiar una vez al año después de
haberla cambiado a eso se refiere con 51
así que en el caso de una hipoteca con
tasa ajustable tu pago se va a ver algo
así y bueno solamente voy a poner
números a pongo números al azar por
simplicidad sólo para darte una idea de
cómo de cómo funciona esto en el caso de
51 los primeros cinco años son fijos así
que los meses se ven algo así el mes 1
el mes 2 hasta llegar al mes 60 que
sería el último mes de los 5 años 5 por
12 meses son 60 12 y 60 esto es en el
transcurso de cinco años y en el
transcurso de cinco años la idea es muy
similar una parte de las barras
indicarán qué
son los intereses y lo restante será
usado para pagar el préstamo como te
estoy indicando aquí y bueno en cada mes
vas a pagar un poquito más de la deuda y
un poquito menos de intereses aquí va a
ser un poquito más de la deuda y un poco
más de intereses aunque casi no se nota
así que lo voy a borrar entonces algo
así eso es para la deuda y acá está para
los intereses así sucesivamente hasta
llegar al mes 60 y bueno vas a pagar
menos de intereses porque debes menos a
tu deuda y en el año 5 aún no has pagado
deuda así que el interés están quizás
por aquí o bueno un poquito más arriba
tal vez eso es lo que estás pagando tu a
tu deuda y acá está lo que estás pagando
de tu deuda en verde para una hipoteca
de tasa ajustable mixta después de un
periodo de cinco años el banco ahora lo
que puede hacer es cambiar la tasa de
interés y la tasa de interés depende de
algo muy importante a lo cual todos
están poniendo mucha atención a que
incrementa el interés así que en el caso
de hipoteca de tasa ajustable 51 como
puedes ver
con una tasa del 3% y por esta cosa lo
que estamos poniendo tensión bueno alta
te voy a decir de qué trata de lo que
estoy hablando las tasas de interés un
de repente suben y digamos que suben
mucho entonces un de repente tu pago
puede incrementar y tu pago puede
incrementar porque la idea general
detrás de una hipoteca de tasa ajustable
51 es que aún tendrás que pagar en 30
años entonces tienes un término de 30
años así que si te quedas con ese
préstamo si nunca intentas pedir otro
préstamo para reemplazarlo a lo que se
le llama refinanciamiento entonces
tomará 30 años para liquidarlo pero
después de los primeros cinco años la
cantidad de interés que pagas puede
cambiar por ende tu pago podría cambiar
si la tasa sube tendrás que pagar más en
intereses en el mes 61 lo que es
equivalente al año 6 así que la barra
para el año 6 se va a ver algo así
constantemente más intereses
y algo para el pago en el año 6 como es
una hipoteca de tasa ajustable 51 no
podrá cambiar la tasa no puede cambiar
la tasa otra vez hasta el año 7 y de
hecho hay límites para fijar un nuevo
porcentaje de taza cada año o cuando
pueden cambiar la tasa en su totalidad
pero si claro esto implica más riesgo
porque tú no sabes qué cantidad tendrás
que pagar en el año se hizo en el año 7
especialmente imagina que las tasas
aumenten mucho y quizás te pregunte es
bueno qué determina este nuevo
porcentaje en las tasas de interés
después de los 5 años que lo determina
lo que hacen es mirar un índice el más
común es valores de tesorería por
ejemplo la tasa de interés que debe
pagar el gobierno cuando pide un
préstamo
normalmente tomarán una prima sobre esto
las tesorerías de 10 años en el 2% el
banco quizás pondrá en tu documento del
préstamo que después del periodo inicial
de cinco años tú pagarás una tasa de
tesorería más digamos que el 1% así que
inicias pagando el 3%
eso es fijo aún si la tesorería
si hay suceden un millón de cosas aunque
subieran la tesorería 5% el 3% está fijo
tú pagas el 3% por los primeros 5 años
pero después en el sexto año digamos que
en el año 6 la tesorería su tasa ha
subido al no sé digamos que 4% entonces
4 por ciento entonces por contrato por
lo que está en el documento en tu
documento tendrás que pagar eso más el
1% entonces tu hipoteca ahora se va a
regularizar a una tasa del 5% una tasa
más alta pero también podrías tener
suerte quizás la tasa para tesorerías
baje quizás baje al 1% entonces tu tasa
de hipotecas sería del 1 por ciento más
1% así que bajaría al 2%
eso es suerte pero la idea general es
que qué implica más riesgo las tasas de
interés cotizadas
si las observas te darás cuenta que la
tasa fija a 30 años es más alta que la
de 15 años que es más alta que la
ajustable eso sucede aunque hay
diferentes tipos de riesgo pero sucede
porque el banco está tomando
el menor riesgo en la tasa ajustable y
tomando más riesgo en la fija a 30 años
y el mayor riesgo aquí es que no lo
pagues pero para eso es el desembolso
inicial porque así ellos pueden obtener
la casa esperando que la casa no se
devalúe pero aún más que eso hay un
riesgo en la tasa de interés porque qué
sucede si el banco te prestó en el 5% y
las tasas suben al 6% o 7% 8% qué pasa
si suben al 10% imagina sería un caos
total para el banco ellos estarían
perdiendo en el préstamo que te hicieron
en este caso lo están dejando fijo por
tantos años y bueno de esa manera ellos
están ellos están arreglando sus
ganancias cobrando temas intereses en el
caso de 15 años implica menos riesgo por
eso tiene menor interés es menor
porcentaje en el caso 51 a un menor
riesgo solo está fijo por 5 años y
después de eso esto flota con el interés
actual en una base anual y bueno espero
que esta explicación te haya dado una
idea de lo que son las tasas de interés
quiero que este vídeo sea suficiente
para
saber qué harías a la hora de pedir un
préstamo y bueno claro también es muy
importante leer todo el papeleo todos
los detalles de lo que de lo que son los
diferentes tipos de préstamos
especialmente si te quieres lanzar por
un préstamo exótico como como el
ajustable 51 y bueno nos vemos